all right melanie
melanie where'd you grow up where are
you from version yeah originally chicago
and indianapolis those two cities
tell me about your family
my family okay my father worked at
general motors and he was out here in la
in the 70s
and like parts of the 80s that type of
thing and then after that happened
it's like you know with jim they kind of
forced everybody out so what he was
trying to do is stay within the cali
region which kind of just didn't work
out in his favor because they were
telling him you got to go here go here
we're giving you a list of choices
narrowed it down
and that's when they forced him to
kansas city and that's where i was born
what was your relationship like with
your parents
with my parents was kind of like hectic
like my father in particular
like per se
was more like the movie blow boston
george
like a functioning alcoholic so i had to
deal with that and then later on finding
out the drug use that he had so they
like explained everything
you know for the thesis of the story of
why it was never nothing to eat in the
refrigerator coming home and you have a
parent
that has a good job
car all that
but it's never nothing in the fridge and
then sometimes rent would be dull and
you'd be struggling with that so and my
mother was more of the type that was an
enabler
as long as she had to like toxicity and
drama stirred up within
her realm and she was happy like that's
she put everybody against each other so
it was like that and i was kind of like
raised by my uncle
which when we left kansas city to
indianapolis and then that's when like
things didn't work so they shipped me to
chicago my uncle
so like with that
it was like chaotic in the 90s because
like
you couldn't be like how i am now
and so my brother i was stuck with him
transgender
yeah i couldn't do none of that i was
already like dibbling dabbling in it
playing with my mother's pantsuits out
there taking her shoulder pads out
making a gaffe out of it for that
nail polish i was doing like everything
but you know in the 90s when we moved
away from kansas city and then
indianapolis like i said in chicago
fights break out the gangs vice lords
gangster disciples all that like i've
never seen none of that until i got to
that part of the country and it was like
serious you had to learn how to fight
and like survive every day
chicago's rough
very rough like i mean it's the belly of
the beast honestly it's like you gotta
like jump off the porch immediately
eight nine years old i've done that it's
like you gotta find a way like
left home alone
all throughout the nights watching
myself
like my mother she was selective on who
she cherished and loved like
majority of my brothers and sisters all
of them were born out here in cali
southern cali my brother's harbor city
my sister lynnwood
then i have another sister like i said
she was born in first now so
you you
kind of realize that you were
trans at an early age
yeah i did like kind of everybody
noticed that my aunties noticed that
and they were like telling my father
like you need to get that one with the
inside eye and the underwear and like
playing with care bear and stuff like
that but i could never express it
because like the ridicule the backlash
the mayhem
and then like you would be fighting
coming home from school and to school
and nobody wants to hear your story so i
mean what are you gonna do
you think your
sexual
orientation um comes from something that
happened to you or you were born this
way
more like i already knew when i was a
kid something did happen like with a
relative a cousin
they left me with
um you know like stuff kind of went on
from there i kind of fended out for a
little bit so i mean
that kind of happened a little bit
that was like when i was about nine
like we'd be left in the house by
herself and then my cousin was probably
like
five years older than
you've been driving a truck for how long
now okay let's see i've been driving the
truck for about like literally
it's gonna be three years within about
like three months
you'll drive all over the country yeah
that will have you going coast to coast
and like i said that's very dangerous
like
the dynamics of trucking is like very
it's set up for where all the companies
make money for their stuff and it's like
a pimping industry because they only
give the drivers a little bit like you
should get a percentage and in charge of
the driver low board picking your own
loads so you can go ahead and see where
you want to drive and pre-plan yourself
instead they have a driver manager it's
called a dispatcher
barely knows anything about the [ __ ]
business and literally
they go home
don't care about you
mess the load up they can have you
picking up a load it's called like a
repower you just go pick up a load
that's late delivery and they never
reschedule anything so you might get to
the place and mind you tight-ass roads
or back roads dangerous [ __ ]
they'll give you the wrong address now
you got to figure out where to go and
they won't pick up and dispatch is the
worst because if you call them half of
the time they don't care and they don't
know because they don't correspond it's
like communication is very shocked
within trucking and that's why drivers
will quit after a while because like
zero experience
and you're from one side of the country
like the midwest
and you want me to drive all the way
like to seattle portland going up to
cascades and people have never seen it
in winter time they get scared
and they don't know how to like
deal with it with their anxiety all that
and they put a lot in front of you and
they really don't care like
it's just they want to say you have to
have experience going up and down
mountains
and driving over tr which is over the
road that's a lie because you can get
hired and do local but they don't tell
you nothing they want you to come in as
a company driver which is like slave for
peanuts for them
two years experience want to give you 48
cents per mile or something like that
close to it when you should be getting
55 cents per hour at 60. and then some
of them don't put apu's in the truck
which those are outlets to where you can
plug in stuff that you need and that is
like kills everything and then they have
an idle policy on some of these
companies where
they only want you idling in the truck
for a little bit and it's hot as [ __ ]
and like what am i gonna do burn up in
the truck
it's like crazy and they don't clean
these trucks neither that's another
thing i have a problem with it they put
you in a truck they got bed bugs i've
been through that four times in
2021 drove from rancho cucamonga all the
way to san antonio
getting bit the [ __ ] up when texas had
that winter storm i think it was 20 20.
i was just trying to haul my ass back
home
get to san antonio that's where i was
living at the time
it was chaotic like they don't give you
a personal convenience which that's a
button if all your drive time is out
because you got 70 hours to drive period
for the week
14 hours you can't push the limits of oh
no they will they'll try to violate but
here's i'm gonna get into that next you
got 11 hours to drive straight and they
really feel like you should just sit in
the [ __ ] seat all day and take no
breaks and drive 11 hours in total like
no i need to get the [ __ ] off this truck
if i lose my mind and that's exactly
what happens majority of the time
and people like get frantic and quick
because you know you got all types of
things people cutting you off cutting in
the lane you can't get over you're in a
brand new city i must say like the
shittiest ones are dallas and atlanta
because they go like this
and it's hard to navigate and you're
stuck in traffic and people like park
the truck on the side of the road and
quit like especially with the bed bugs
because you got to replace everything
they don't reimburse you they don't care
they know the trucks are nasty
and then on top of that um
like they just say you go wash and dry
your clothes i'm like [ __ ] really you
don't reimburse me for that no they
don't even do that
so i mean trucking is brutal unless
you're an operator you gotta save up all
your ends
figure it out least purchase maybe you
know you renting a truck through their
company which is still making them a
[ __ ] ton of money and they're getting
profit and gross right you're just
getting increments
and they lie also about i want to say
what is it they lie about the most
really home time that's one of them
that's why a lot of us park the truck
quick because they want you out on the
road three to four weeks and before you
want to go home they always give you an
extra stop way out of the way
and then um the other thing that makes
people quit is uh the benefits suck i
want to say i always want to say it's a
bonus
but the bonus they break it down in
increments first check you get maybe
500. next check within 60 days if you
stay see all this is stretched out over
a period of time so they can have driver
retention
you know so they don't their turnover
rate's not high
and that's the games they play in
trucking and they really don't care
about drivers and drivers are in and out
the door then you want to go independent
and drive for somebody like i've indeed
or glass door
but the catch to that is they do 10.99
so now you're paying for every [ __ ]
thing out of your pocket
taxes included you got to do the whole
bracket and it's like damn you get no
benefits
and the day you quit as a company driver
they literally cut your [ __ ]
insurance off that damn [ __ ] day
and that's what like killed me is like
i'm trying to really get my life
together using trucking i did it because
like
i'm on child support for a kid that's
not mine which that's my foster
brother's kid like to get into that
that's a mess and kind of reason why i
gave up on
dealing with women in general like it
was just hectic and chaotic and nothing
you ever do enough it's good enough for
them that's what i'm trying to say they
always find something [ __ ] complain
about this that the third
and i'm you know the worst thing you can
do is really write somebody else's kid
because you have no jurisdiction
especially where i'm at you know what
i'm talking about they let the kids run
all over you be in the grocery store
sliding with slippers and cussing them
out
come on right pookie this that man like
it's crazy you know i got tired of it i
was in that this relationship literally
i want to say
nine years it was toxic as hell i wish i
would have saved myself and got out
earlier
but you know when somebody has a kid and
then boom have another one what are you
gonna do run out on her while the kids a
little that's i was like nah
but
i don't know that's kind of like my
story with them you know going into
trucking for their child support and
that's my first kids mom
like literally i was like scared i was
19 2005 like how do i get off child
support i don't know how
do i like go down to the dungeon that's
what i call it because
it's all the way in the basement like
indianapolis jail and stuff to set up
where you got to go all the way
underground even to walk the court
so i'm like i don't know what papers
they was pushing in my face signed
whatever i thought it was maybe sign for
paternity it wasn't so i ended up on the
hook for that
and i was literally in job corps trying
to like get my life together then and
get a trade which i did obtain like
plastering and drywall
you know it wasn't what i wanted because
everything was filled up i just took
what i could but when i came home this
is how i knew this was messed up with
the foster kid
my
mother picked me up dropped me off
whatever the foster kid was in my
father's room
laid out on the bed
and as i'm looking i'm like what is this
person doing you know
he was sitting there like
bad ass naked
in her bed and like his withdrawals
whatever i'm like okay so y'all too
[ __ ] so not only he [ __ ] my baby
mama
at the time whatever and he [ __ ] my
mama too so i'm like immediately we
started like fighting and stuff like
that because she always used to foster
kids for money really didn't give a [ __ ]
about them period
and like that's what it was they were
her cash cow and
like it was what it was and she really
didn't want me because she had eight or
nine abortions i figured that game plan
out too with her literally
are drugs are part of your life
really drugs i've never like dived into
my drug of choice would be that liquor
store like anything like vodka everybody
like knows me knows that i can drink
down some [ __ ] very quickly like but you
know my part of the country is liquor
store on every corner you can't just not
walk and run into one where do you live
right now
no right now i'm in the bronx new york
but chicago where i grew up at between
that
and indianapolis is like liquor store is
literally on every freaking corner you
walk to that corner that corner
so it's like you can't escape it it's
designed to keep you trapped
are you happy or is it a woman
yeah definitely i'd have to figure like
majority of it out because like being
trans you get ridiculed people rank you
through the codes give you dirty looks
whatever sometimes you
look like huh it's this person looking
at me a funny way like my trans or
they're gonna say something sometimes
like they do say things and out of the
way if you're having a bad day and
you're not like coordinated right got
everything
together like dots your t's and stuff
and they notice it and nitpick with you
or say something out of the blue and you
really try to keep your calm composure
but like sometimes you just go off and
it just happens like with me
i don't know how i really didn't go off
on anybody yet i try to like stay in my
own little realm world but mentally it
has exhausted me i just want to get
somewhere where i can be like helped
you know out there and figure out me
like where the other trans are at that
kind of like show you the ends out to
do's and don'ts i like because i just
started transitioning in 2021 in the
beginning you're taking hormones
yeah i'm taking hormones all that i'm
trying to save up that's what i was
using trucking for like for that
but sometimes i get burned out with
trucking and like where am i going to go
to move to because i was living off the
truck that was the big that was like my
shelter
wherever the truck went i went and then
when i had to get off because i mentally
fatigued because the last company had me
out 60 days straight
and lied and said it was going to send
me home never did
and um
long story short they had bedbugs in
that damn truck
and she said i was the reason why
the bed bugs was brought in because i
went to walmart and bought the mattress
i'm like damn every time you buy stuff
get comfortable with trucking boom
it's a problem you end up leaving and
most truckers get mad about this they
noticed they didn't left so much [ __ ] on
that damn truck and lost so much money
they invested in and then like i ain't
worth them losing more money than i like
and if like
you keep doing that like celadon is one
of them it's a big ass company everybody
that's watching this will tell you this
they shut everything down they had some
type of big-ass scheme they were
stealing and not paying taxes and
everything else so they just shut
everything down left drivers stranded
they'll do that leave you stranded they
cut off the fuel cars cut off everything
people were scrambling
all the way across country didn't even
know how to get back in remote towns
like montana i know some people were in
tennessee and they're from over this way
and i'm like i don't know how to get
back like seriously and
some of the driver managers at the time
would laugh and they would think that
was funny so yeah trucking is
complicated very
unless you own that truck and even if so
the fuel economy is so damn bad it kind
of force you to
is it quit to save money
trucking yeah because it's designed like
to take away from me i mean let's be
serious loves pilot tas all these truck
stops high as [ __ ] if you got to eat
pretty much from that
i mean it's like 25 damn dollars each
meal it's expensive then they want to
pimp you on the parking you can't park
here you got to pay 20 and it's like you
got to keep riding around sometimes even
you get out this way it's 40. and i'm
like damn you just keep losing money i
mean that's it's crazy
and even if you buy stuff for the truck
that's another thing you might need
cushions because when you ride you just
can't ride in the seats you're back
going while you got to get the back
piece the companies don't even issue
those things out they you would think
they would go ahead and give you all
this for the driver to be comfortable
going up and down raggedy as mountains
the appalachians from which i've seen in
your interviews you should know so
i hate that like send you through
virginia
i've been in virginia and i had the
wrong gps lady like just to get this gps
um she was like doing the orientation
this was out of gary indiana so i'm like
okay cool
i did that she said yeah this was one
really didn't give a [ __ ] she just sent
me on my way i got up there to the back
roads of va
not knowing [ __ ] it took me through some
rinky-dink town
and i kept going up like this through
the mountains i'm like ooh [ __ ] trucks
prohibited i'm like i don't got no
turnaround though so what am i going to
do i got to write it out
went
further up this [ __ ] it looked like he
was going to enter the damn [ __ ] drop
song at like kings island or use on a
roller coaster
this happens too so i didn't notice this
part i got all the way up there the
truck just shut the [ __ ] off on me start
rocking back and sliding back i'm like
oh [ __ ] i kicked the door open i'm like
i'm about to jump [ __ ] this truck [ __ ]
everything in the back i'm done they had
this [ __ ] i don't care no more ain't
worth me while i'm dying going over the
cliff and i'm like [ __ ] what am i going
to do i do need a cdl because when i'm
going to go back to bell tire discount
tire changing tires what i was doing
before
what oil lube technician i don't like
doing that or two man in the truck i was
doing these things i don't do that no
more so i'm like let me figure this out
and i don't got that much time so i
pulled the brakes tilted a little bit
which has stopped and if it went further
that way it was going off the cliff i'm
like [ __ ] okay i can't get reception i'm
all the way up in the hills what the
[ __ ] do i do
not to be funny but i was like okay what
do white people do in scary movies they
text 9-1-1
so i say let me text
i'm like look i'm stuck i don't know
where i'm at get out and look i said
like hell [ __ ] i ain't nothing up here
but what fox wolves and it really was
i'm looking at them i'm not getting out
no i'm like black people don't make it
out of these scary situations
you know i'm not lying i'm like okay i
can't do it so
i called the company
they don't answer they really don't give
a [ __ ] it's just you whatever that's
your problem so the police finally did
send somebody out there they knew the
area
then he looked on the side they sent a
fuel truck that's what it was to give me
because i ran out of fields somebody
siphoned my fuel out
in my first year of trucking it's like i
was a magnet owner operators dear domain
wants to steal and siphon your fuel so
they took all my damn fuel i didn't know
out of one tank and that's why i ran the
[ __ ] out i literally was looking at the
light but sometimes when you've been
driving on e you have a long distance to
go in that truck
then as i thought the close was the
coast was clear going down like that
taking up all the lanes because i mean
literally you don't have no room to like
pretty much have distance to keep from
going over
it all [ __ ] happens at the end so i got
to the end thing and the coast is clear
boom hill big railroad type thing
smashed both of my drive tires i think
let me see no trailer tires it was the
trailer the back side of the trailers
smashed them ran bent to hell i'm like i
knew something was wrong once again like
i'm telling you i don't i'm in this
field area i don't want to get out so i
have ass i just seen a ta up the hill i
think that was a petrol my petrol so i
said
i'm hauling ass i'm getting up there
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i gotta get up after this
truck so i
hit the gas again
got up there they changed everything and
like said from there i was kind of free
but sometimes they'll put that on your
record any accidents any type of thing
they can get
they put it on your record and try to
like [ __ ] on you so other drivers that's
trying to get hired it's like they have
i think it's an intelli app and then
something else your dac report that's
what it is so
every time companies are looking at your
dac report
they want to see pretty much are you
hirable is my insurance gonna take you
on and it's the games you gotta think in
your head like how do i stay safe and
protect my [ __ ] insurance dlt is the
police that pulls you over they'll hit
you as well
illinois the bottom half of illinois
going into st louis smacked me real bad
this was like um i was leaving san
antonio trying to get back to
indianapolis i got lied to
i had family there that was like oh you
can save money move in with us i'm like
shinna did it but i was ready to leave
san antonio because my
landlord i was pretty much renting a
room
because my credit's so damn [ __ ] up
don't matter how much money i get now
like i got the money to pay the rent oh
well i'm sorry your credit or they just
make up some story we'll mail you
something just tell me i'm [ __ ] up
with credit this barrier tell me i might
as well go ahead and pitch attend
somewhere or
i mean seriously it's bad so i don't
like being lied to and i know one way to
check my credit
go apply for little credit cards for big
lots any type of way
i want to say coles department store and
if you don't get that you know your
credit's in the dump so i already know
i'm like okay i can like leave san
antonio real quick because my landlord
was messing with me anyway like
oh yeah he's gay this thing in the third
and i can get him to do this and do that
because i wasn't fully out but i was
like on my way to coming out some [ __ ]
did happen to where like rent got behind
and i had to mess with him in order to
pay
my [ __ ] half like i was trying to
keep my money
i want me to pay some of my debt off to
clear this [ __ ] off so i can get my name
good and pay the bank off somebody else
and that's bad because my mom used my
credit up bad my name and [ __ ] it up
turned on a lot of [ __ ] my name she did
a lot of foul [ __ ] to me
and then
throws that i'm a church godly woman i
bet so i mean
whatever i just know you use my credit
and mess my [ __ ] up
and i know you went to the church before
too i also [ __ ] the pastor and don't
want to mention it
seriously like they sent her home one
day because her skirt was too short i'm
like man looking at my father at the
time i'm like you're simply still with
her
but i figured she puts up with his [ __ ]
and i don't know he jacks off the money
that's for different type of women and
every time when i was a kid he would use
me as his um go-to to like cover for me
why say i was doing this i was doing
that even when i was a kid like covered
for him from cheating say the condoms in
the truck was yours
all type of crazy [ __ ]
and get caught with calls and stuff on
his phone she would check it i don't
know like my middle name is justin
justin must have been on my phone justin
did this i'm like
nah i didn't do [ __ ] that was all you
but you need to take ownership of your
fuck-ups like seriously and even when i
was a kid he would blow his money and
jack it off ain't got no money to smoke
up the dope with him and his friends he
would show off and flex in front of his
friends like take care of them more than
he took her
family and kids me
i'm like
okay cool as a kid that you get money
thinking you're gonna keep the money but
he will take the money from you and be
like i'll pay you back with interest you
ain't seen that [ __ ] back for about five
months and that's for him and his
friends go get high and drunk and go
trick off on whatever [ __ ] crackhead
[ __ ] he can find
knew that as a kid i'm like [ __ ]
that explains why i was in the streets
running with gangs too
like stealing like boosting everything
in sight
because you got to have it like you
didn't want to be without seriously like
it was all bad like i was getting mad
about it you see other kids having a lot
of stuff and you looking
of course i know how to make fun of
people good but it all makes sense to
make fun of somebody when you sit over
there looking raggedy and not having so
i just learned pretty much skill to
trade from eight nine ten
be a master thief but no never steal
from your community your people
you gotta have morals and concepts about
in virtues so i'm like i'm just hit
retail because they're insuranced anyway
and um corporate america ain't gonna
miss [ __ ] that's how i looked at it
they're robbing from us so let me take
from them
what would you say is the most important
lesson you learned in your life
the most important lessons is like
protect your energy protect like your
peace of mind
and sometimes if things get too chaotic
and you got to get away and you got to
disappear to get like a peace of mind
and collect everything again and find
you again do that because life is too
short to be nice and trying to be there
for people and they're not there for you
so you got to watch everything including
friends family because people like
coming the devil in disguise they'll
play you manipulate you then when they
don't got a need for you they discard
you like a dirty tampon and they out of
your life like that and use them we're
stuck [ __ ] up and that's life that's
how it goes it's like you got to play it
in before they play you
all right melanie thank you so much for
sharing your story no problem be careful
driving out there mm-hmm thank you no
problem
you